you're typically on friday the friday
draft is guys under pressure the tuesday
draft is essentially the guys who
cracked under pressure the goats of the
week not in a good way apparently the
kids only think of goat in a good way
this is goat in a bad way
i assume since they didn't send me a
trivia question you're going to be
asking me the question today i'll get it
wrong and then you'll have the first
pick i have the trivia question and you
are right i assume that goat was in a
good way and then uh when stats texted
me it was like hey just to clarify it's
goat in a bad way i realized the mistake
i made because mike florio would never
praise anyone for anything ever uh okay
so the draft question ready for it yeah
i'm right i really like your jacket
that's a great jacket you have there i
love your jacket all right kenyon drake
was traded yesterday he scored the td in
the miami miracle play last year
four skill position players touched the
ball on that play but only one is still
on the dolphins roster who is that
player i have a hint if you need it
i don't need it it's jakeem grant nope
you did need it it's devante parker you
did need it you are
the hubris
oh my god
he catches passes
oh okay well that one that's not much of
a hint
that's something i still would have said
you keem grant i just i i just uh i i
thought that you know what if i'm gonna
be wrong
uh what the hell if i'm gonna be right
at least it comes off that i knew what i
was talking about even though i didn't
okay you get the first pick go ahead all
right first picks easy one i you know
you could see that i was getting
frustrated in the first hour about it
i've been frustrated for two days matt
nagy and his decision-making at the end
of the game his decision-making
throughout the entire game
is just crazy and you know basically
contradicting himself where he where he
says we we didn't want to throw we
didn't want to pass
sorry we didn't want to run because we'd
give up a few yards we didn't want to
pass because if we took a sack we would
be sacked out of field goal range even
though right before that he had said we
already were in field goal range when
they uh before they got the 11 yard
matt nagy is
at a crossroads here because the biggest
problem when you have a coach who makes
decisions like this and panics is will
he step in front of the podium and say
hey guys i screwed up i messed up
freddie kitchen's a great example he
said i messed up i got to be better matt
nagy goes the opposite route he thinks
he's smarter than everyone he gets up
there and says no i would never change
what i did i would do it a thousand
times more he digs his feet into the
sand and he says i am not relenting at
all what i'm the decision-making i made
was perfect that's essentially what he's
saying so he now when he does that is
opening himself up to criticism and
being able to you know people go at him
because he is saying i'm smarter than
you and i know exactly how to coach this
team and everyone needs to kind of go
away while i make these decisions
and he's not going to get the benefit of
the doubt from the media in chicago
because there is a contentious
relationship there and there's been a
contentious relationship a contentious
vibe between the team and the media
generally in recent years i mean
don't you have to be
somewhat accomplished as an organization
to be that aloof and standoffish when it
comes to the media and the problem with
a coach who doesn't have the media on
his side and this is such an easy thing
to do we are we are very easily bought
as media just be nice to us right when
you act like a hard ass when you you
know when when you and i'm not just
saying nagy i'm saying this is the
formula when you act a certain way and
it alienates the media when things go
poorly they are going to come after you
unless you win you're not going to get
away with being that way because
ultimately this comes down to human
interactions and matt niggy's
endangering the bears are in danger of
having the media there rip them even
more mercilessly than they currently are
all right mine i'm gonna go to the
saints cardinals game because you know
we've talked about new coaches making
decisions that don't work and then
doubling down fourth and one on their
own 30 cliff kingsbury decides not to
punt the ball and then calls up a run
into the middle of the line of scrimmage
the teeth of the saints defense when
that was an opportunity it's ten to six
at that point midway through the third
quarter the cardinals had just gotten a
turnover but what they did by failing to
convert there by going for it giving the
saints a short field they took advantage
of it they scored a touchdown made it
17-6 and that was that but it was a bad
decision it was a bad call of a play
you've got kyle murray there a guy
you've called a generational talent keep
the ball in his hands from more than
just a hand off from under center and uh
it just did look i'm not saying the
cardinals would have won the game but it
wouldn't have been 31-9 and they may
have had a chance to take the lead or at
least make it more interesting down the
stretch than it was and then after the
game
doubles down no regrets analytics back
me up all the things instead of you know
what maybe i shouldn't have done that
maybe that was a turning point from a
momentum standpoint because it was the
game changed at that point and if they
had just punted the ball they maybe
would have had a chance to keep it going
i have no problem with that play call
you're so wrong on that when you're an
underdog when you're a double-digit
underdog in someone else's stadium you
have to take your chances you have to
take your shots you're not going to win
that game you're still got 70 yards
mike you're not going to win that game
playing straight up you're not going to
win that you need to steal possessions
10 to 6. you can say the play call might
not have been great but going for it
there i have no problem with the whole
bash a guy for being too conservative
there too and so you're you're this is
no no not on your own
it's ten to six ten to six don't care
midway through the third quarter gotta
take shots how did you feel about how
did you feel about mike zimmer going for
what we did we argued about that on
friday you liked mike zimmer going
forward on fourth and short from his own
35 you liked that you did well that's a
different weight that's why he liked it
he said it was the dumbest decision he
ever made the next that's also a totally
different that's a totally different
circumstance because the vikings are
going to win that game no matter what
going away
and the cardinals are an underdog a
double-digit underdog in new orleans you
have to take your chances you have to do
something to tilt this game if he gets
that and they go down and score he's a
genius so i don't like that by you
that's a terrible pick all right my next
pick all right make your next pick i'm
gonna go with andy reid and look andy
reid had a had a had a nice game with
matt moore makes matt moore look good
i'm not even gonna go at him for the
punt the decision to punt the ball with
five minutes left and they don't get the
ball back by the way matt nagy learned
from your uh mentor andy reid in the
press conference after said you could
see it both ways you you could debate it
both ways that decision to punt the ball
he totally understands that he'd be
second guessed there that's how you do a
press conference when you say that when
you say hey look i understand why people
would think that that was the wrong
decision but my problem with andy reid
and the goat
is
the play clock the the the the time andy
reid verse time is one of the greatest
rivalries in actually you know what it's
not a rivalry because time keeps winning
mike and angry not being able to figure
out how the clock works at the end of
games is insane i do not understand it
he is one of the best coaches of all
time and he doesn't know how the clock
works he calls the timeout with 241 left
when the packers had to run a play
before the two minute warning
essentially gifting them 40 seconds if
he saves the time out if he lets the
packers have to run a play before the
two-minute warning he then gets the
time-out on the other side of the
two-minute warning and compensation
could potentially get the ball back with
a minute and 50 instead he burns 40
seconds not understanding simple math
andy reid you need a clock coordinator
figure it out you need a clock
coordinator
it is amazing to have a coach who is so
accomplished has has enjoyed so much
success over the last 20 years and would
have a flaw like that that just can't be
fixed like so what what happens in those
moments on the sideline and it just it
it proves something that i've always
said these games take on a life of their
own and when you're in the middle of
that when it's happening it's so
different than if you're watching it on
tv that you just it's so easy to get
lost in everything that's that's going
on that you just don't make a rational
decision that's exactly right so i had a
friend who pointed out to me after i
mentioned it on uh sunday's part of my
take that actually andy reid as smarty
as he is with football we actually his
fans know how the clock works more than
he does because we watch every single
game and we watch every single late game
situation whereas andy reid watches a
lot of film and he only is in the game
situation when he's in the game
situation on a sunday afternoon you're
watching ten two minute warnings hit and
you're watching all these times where
where the clock comes into play andy
reid isn't watching that as much so we
actually are better at clock management
than andy reid because we have more
practice by just watching it more than
he does
and we play madden and we play matt i'm
not i'm not being facetious that's part
of it you play madden you understand how
to manage a clock that's an easy
transferable aspect of the video game to
the actual game managing the clock and
working your timeouts and making sure
you get the ball back or you keep the
other team from getting the ball all
right next one for me i got to go with
freddy kitchens we talked about it
earlier in the show this whole i'm just
learning as i go and also it's it's an
extra goat award because on friday he
came out and he was just flat out angry
with the media because of the way the
media had interpreted the things that
jarvis landry had said the day before
when he said we're going to win the game
it's what jarvis landry said it was a
fair characterization of what he said
and that just had me in a salty mood
about freddie going into the week but
when you throw on top of it deliberately
taking a penalty on fourth and 11 when
your punt team goes out there because
you didn't tell your sidelines don't
send the punt team out there and then
you take the penalty so you can go for
it on fourth and 16. that that's even
though they weren't going to win that
game goat horns for freddie kitchens
okay i like that yep all right let's do
this let's do this
because we're going to run out of time
let's give you my question let's pause
oh i'll give you a quick one you want to
do a quick one yeah
vic fangio everything joe flacco said
was correct you're a two and five team
you got to be more aggressive in that
situation
all right quick one for me adrian hill
he was the referee in the titans
buccaneers game and even though he's not
the one who blew the whistle the
explanation he gave afterward that the
quick the quick whistle is the kiss of
death it took away a potential victory
from the tampa bay buccaneers the ball
was out on that fake field goal that
brett kern was trying to run for the
first down they blew the whistle they
killed it's the third time i think this
year that's affected a game uh whatever
happened to let it all play out adrian
hill's the crew chief he's responsible
for making sure his people know not to
blow the whistle they failed he gets the
goat horns
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports